I tried to commit suicide a couple of
times
because it was so dark I didn't think it
would get any better had any of those
attempts happened
I would have missed the best part of my
life Tyler Perry is opening up about his
past suicide attempts in the wake of
Stephen twitch boss's death I like the
rest of the world I'm shocked shortly
after news broke on Wednesday that
twitch died by Suicide the media Mogul
shared that emotional clip to Instagram
revealing his past failed attempts to
take his own life and encouraging fans
to find comfort in his story I'm the
happiest I've ever been
life is full of joy and love if you are
a person who is considering suicide or
ending your life
and you've already been through a lot of
Hell please please please
think about what the other side could be
it could be amazing and you would miss
the best part of it going through the
darkness
don't let the darkness stop you from
getting to this incredible place of
light Tyler captioned the post Simply
Life dot dot dot and the death of twitch
is heartbreaking
seriously heartbreaking meanwhile Rosie
O'Donnell got candid about her
experience with depression on Tick Tock
posting a video of the sunset alongside
the text twitch I've been on
antidepressants since 1999 right after
Columbine and I will never go off them
because I know how dark it gets and I
know how bad it could be and it can make
you forget
that you have children who need you that
you have friends who would mourn you
forever but you have siblings who
wouldn't survive you know you forget
those things
in the throes of depression but Rosie
like Tyler shared a similar message of
Hope but it seems like there's not a
possibility for you to recover there is
good life's worth living twitch was best
known as the house DJ on The Ellen
Degeneres Show from 2014 until the
series ended earlier this year twitch
you want to know my favorite thing that
we've added what's your favorite thing
though it's you
and during his tenure on the show he
became an executive producer filming the
last episode of Ellen that it was really
the the end of an era and and also it
was so emotional and so inspiring I'm
just so grateful but twitch first rose
to Fame in 2008 as the runner-up on So
You Think You Can Dance I tried out for
the show for season fours I told myself
if I did if I didn't make the show when
I got cut then that like my next move
would be to the uh the office of the
Navy to enlist so I would literally be
doing something completely different had
it not worked out
and on Wednesday twitch's fellow So You
Think You Can Dance Alum Alex Wong also
spoke out fighting back tears on Tick
Tock with an important message I just
wanna
remind everyone that
reach up to
the ones that you love
and don't take anyone for in it
Love You Stephen
[Music]